ladies and gentlemen I'd like to
introduce the creators of Game of
Thrones David Benioff and DB Weiss
director Miguel Sahaj Nick liam
Cunningham
John Bradley
Nathalie Emmanuel
on the hill
sophie turner it 1 Rihanna
play more say
Isaac Hempstead right and finally first
in Nair
so I'd like to start with the elephant
in the room it's uh it's been announced
that next season will only be seven
episodes and will not air until the
summer so I guess my first question to
David and Dan is why do you hate us all
so much
it seems personal well you know I guess
the Sophie said in that clip winter is
here and we got a shoot in places where
there are trees and we gotta wait for
the leaves to fall off so we're actually
waiting to shoot later in the year and
that means we don't finish shooting till
February
there's no way to finish post there's no
way to get the show out there until
summer so that doesn't account for the
three Sundays or I will have nothing to
do at night can you walk me through that
in front of 7,000 people and millions of
people who are watching
re-watch and start over at the beginning
that's a good answer
um so there's a plethora of human
history to draw from but is there any
civilization or time period specifically
that you guys draw the most amount of
inspiration in terms of like quest for
power or even any kind of like
Machiavellian real-life characters
throughout history that you can think of
specifically well I think the the books
are sort of built on a skeleton of
medieval Western history but one of the
great things about fantasy is that
you're not bound to what happened so he
George when he wrote his books got to
pick all the bits that he liked the most
and he got to skip this so and so begat
so and so begat so and so part of
history you got to kind of paper over
that and he drew on Mongols he drew on
Native Americans he drew on everything
he was very deeply read in world history
and you know and we get to we get to do
the same thing I mean that's that's one
of the real joys of we're kind of both
history buffs and we get the recounting
the violence of humanity yeah we get to
just look at every awful thing that's
happened in the world not
one part of the world and just cram it
all into you know ten ten hours of seven
hours rather a season I just want to
point out that sophie Turner made us all
do shots of vodka before we came out
here so our I'm 20 I didn't do any of
their are answers might not be as
articulate as they should be okay good
it's just trying to keep it complete
sentences if I can do a complete
sentence I know I'm still in shape what
one of the things you guys just touched
on was that um that obviously you've
drawing from source material but season
six was the first in which you would
pass the books and so I'm obviously next
season will continue to do that can you
talk a little bit about that process and
and you know working with George to
achieve and how much of it is his vision
versus how much of it that you guys want
to do with the show yeah well you know
some of it is still it's still
ultimately George's imagination that
that gave us these characters that gave
us this world and three or four years
ago we were in Santa Fe talking to
George and he told us about where he was
heading with the books and that's when
he told us the Hodor fate and the Hodor
where the name Hodor came from and I
just remember looking at damn it's
George it's George's fault and and I
remember looking at Anna and just we
were both so amazed and excited because
it was so freaking cool and and and one
of the things that's brilliant about it
is that this name which has become
almost a joke you know people make jokes
about Hodor and then ultimately you
realize where that name comes from and
it's suddenly a tragic turn and that's
so george RR martin so hopefully we're
still living out the spirit of you know
George's imagination and even though
we're beyond the books I think one thing
that's fun is that George is kind of
George's books will be very different in
some respects and the same in others and
I think they'll hopefully both the
series and the books will be surprising
to people who are reading or watching or
whatever it is so I Sophie turn it her
fault
well I'm glad you brought something up
because obviously sadly we lost one of
the most beloved characters of the
season and in all of television
I know I know it's not one how did you
how did you create such a lovable scamp
and what is it like to be America's
Sweetheart I'm sorry what was that why
such a lovable scamp Thank You Sophie um
I don't know I mean I think well I think
the key was there that when we were
discussing the character and before we
even start shooting that he had this
kind of joy in everything that he does
so I'm trying he really and he's
enjoying he's on the best time his life
and you know he loves doing all this
stuff and I think having you know it
kind of made him a bit funnier supposed
to he's not just some psychopath that um
that's just one direction he's got a
more about him he's not in one direction
well as an actor obviously you have to
find something you love about the
character that you're playing or at
least understand where he or she is
coming from so where is Ramsay Bolton
coming from I think you know all guys
had a tough upbringing you know he's
he's the bastard in the north which is
always difficult um and you know he's
just looking for his father's love and
acceptance and recognition all his life
and you know it's kind of us obviously
everyone can relate to that
um and hey thanks Zoe um yeah and but
they are very apart from that there's
very very little to like about him I
think when obviously we lost Hodor
thank you guys
Christian can you talk a little bit
about the fans response and what that
was like
I'm sure must have been overwhelming
well um yeah it has been overwhelming I
did not expect it to be so crazy um I'm
really really flattered as well it's
it's blowing my mind like I was in LA a
few days ago in a hotel and them all
their doorsteps or door stop said hodor
on them I got it really but yeah it's
been incredible I didn't expect it I
mean the Seine was incredibly Retton and
directed and I knew it was gonna be cool
but I didn't expect the the outpouring
of emotion you made me cry
all right let's see if we can make them
cry not really well I apologize for that
I apologize for making you cry but
they're crying in a good way at least
okay well I've done my job then I'd like
to do what the show is consistently
doing which is to transition from the
sweet into blood the episodes Battle of
bastards and the winds of winter are
probably the two most astonishing
episodes not only of this show but maybe
any show ever here here yeah
and obviously a lot of that has to do
with the director Miguel supporting
speaking of the battle itself obviously
we could have a whole panel probably
about those two episodes but we have to
limit it to a few questions
um but speaking of the battle itself I
read that originally it was based on the
Battle of Agincourt which took place
between the French and the English in
1415 but as needs changed this is your
quote edited budgets it became more like
the Battle of cannae between the Romans
and Hannibal in 216 can you talk a
little bit about what you meant by that
what what changed and how you changed it
blimey so yeah that originally when we
talked about it the whole idea was to
steep it in history so they wanted a
strategic pitched battle and so the
Battle of Agincourt was I believe it's
the French in the English wasn't it
French in the english fought it out on a
field and the currently from wrong
because I might screw this up completely
the English attacked and the French
encircled them and caught them in a
pincer movement double envelopment and
once they had them in print some of n't
they basically used archers to mow all
these people down and originally we were
going to have a lot of horses like seven
horses deep and they were going to
charge the horses and then actually
surround the allied troops and crush
them with the horses but the problem is
if you run horses at
people they don't like it like the first
time they were right but the second time
they're like I don't really want to run
at these people and third time I'm not
going so I'm guessing the people don't
like it either
well sometimes so the decision was is
that we weren't going to run horses of
people but instead we were going to run
people at people and then there was this
other idea which I always loved and was
probably the first image that I imagined
in my mind when I saw the when I read
the outline which was this pile of
bodies and this was something Dave and
Dan were really keen on and something
that actually we had a lot of kind of
back and forth because initially it felt
like what where does this pile of bodies
come from and then the more research you
did you started realizing when everybody
dies they become a pile of bodies and
gradually this pile of bodies really
gets in the way of you achieving
anything on a battlefield and in fact in
the battle of is it can can I can I
about that can i what was happening as
these people were these heavily armored
Knights were going down into battle and
they were getting stuck between piles of
bodies of dead bodies and they were
becoming sitting ducks to then be picked
off which seemed horrible and a complete
bummer to go out to battle and then you
know get your foot stuck somewhere and
get picked off so that seemed like a
good way to to approach the battle which
is what we did and in terms of budget
constraints would that have something to
do with it it was like this not using
horses was that definitely was a budget
constraint I think anytime you do
something this big you always start with
something that's bigger than you
actually have the money to do and then
what you come up with these creative
ways to turn that disadvantage into an
advantage so there's so many things in
hardhome the year before it was the same
thing in this one you know one of the
reasons that we originally decided to
have the wall of shields that arises was
because we didn't really have the money
to see what was behind the wall of
shields because we've had to stage all
the fighting and dead bodies except
recession we just didn't have the money
to do it even when we were doing the
body pile we had 257 bodies and that
doesn't quite cover the body pile so you
between setups you know ten people from
the art plant will basically run and
move all
to another place and the move body to
another place and it was all about
trying to cover this big pile of chicken
wire that we didn't have the money to
cover well I saw that you're not on the
list for directors this year but we can
expect you back next year I would very
much hope so yes um Liam I was wondering
just from an emotional standpoint did
you read the books no were you aware
before you read the script of the death
of Shireen no no when I got the scripts
the first time I you would have heard
the clang of my jaw hitting the ground
when I read it and and after I read it
that relationship was already there
because we'd already filmed it and to
have her kind of removed from me I'm
that that relationship with terrain was
very easy she's absolutely gorgeous
human being and a beautiful actress and
um these guys keep taking the people I
like working with away from me uh which
makes it difficult but that was um that
was pretty tricky actually am Australian
there is a little story that the the the
stag but I got my daughter is in the
audience here by the way say hello to my
daughter please
so I Eli I liberated the stag and my
daughter has a wall of Awesome at home
and I said you need that out we finish
filming we haven't had me broadcast and
I said you need to you need to have that
in your hand when we're watching the
show we all sit on the couch and watch
it and what I didn't figure on because I
wasn't there for Shireen's demise when
the episode came on I said you need to
have that again yeah and she'll tell you
this she had it in her hand I hadn't
seen it and we sat down to watch it and
all of a sudden my daughter was in a
heap I on the sofa as she watched my
surrogate daughter serene getting born
to death what she held a stag but I had
stolen from and I felt like the worst
dad in the world it was appalling this
awful thing to do so that's their fault
wait away well there's probably not a
more loveable character in the show than
Samwell Tarly I realized when he when he
sees the library that he smiles and you
realize that nobody in this show ever
smiles
except for maybe Cersei but that's I
don't know if that's a smile as much as
it's like an involuntary muscle response
to something evil but it pleases her but
there's a certain sweetness about John
about Samwell in the way that John plays
and not John not John found well yes
John no and I think we can assume that
David and Dan and the world of Game of
Thrones hates sweetness and that
eventually you will be executed inside
so I'm wondering if you if you could
choose the way you will die yeah now is
your opportunity and I think I'd like to
hear and I'm sure they would as well how
wonderful would it be or kind of how the
poetic justice of Sam has always been
told that books are folly and they're to
be dismissed and nobody with any real
common sense ever deals with books he
said no actually no people who read
books can do good in the world they can
do good for the great
yeah see right he's never been around
this many books before he's climbing up
the books show particularly you know
artistic but you know you know book from
the top shell gets all the way up there
doesn't you know severely underestimates
his own weight thank you
you know tipples backwards off the
bookshelf and pulls all of those books
so to erect that you know jaunt young
Miguel you could directly spit right we
saw we saw your work with John under the
bodies in battle of the bastards it was
his Sam trying to fight his way out of
all the books
that he's loved his whole life and now
if he hadn't got what he wanted he'd
still be alive
it wasn't battle that killed him it was
books that killed oh my god that's looks
like a win
Joe writes itself little knowledge is a
dangerous thing
so female empowerment obviously a huge
aspect of season six but really I
believe the series itself uh and I think
that no character personifies that more
than Natalie Emmanuel's character miss
sandy missin Dimas and I Sunday
missandei everybody got a different
pronunciation for that I noticed miss
and a yes Cersei and Danny Breanna
Yara Greyjoy women of strength but so
much of that comes from violence or the
threat thereof whereas miss and I a
former slave who speaks 19 languages
offers something else
compassion intelligence keen insight
into the human condition and in some
ways to me it's the most impressive
trajectory of anybody on the series can
you speak a little bit to miss andis
role in the future of the seven kingdoms
as you see it hmm it's hard to know what
what the future brings for her but I I
think that she genuinely believes in
Daenerys and her claim and Daenerys has
saved her life and liberated her and
acknowledged her brilliance because it's
something that she also has you know
there's these two women that sort of
respect and lift each other up and
it's it's a really sweet friendship and
I guess working relationship as well so
I I kind of hope that Masson day
continues to support Daenerys and they
sort of become well continue to be this
little girl power couple um Conliffe
Varys has time I'm like a stocking that
is not joy it has a huff
he has a seemingly endless array of
spies spy network um obviously he uses
to his advantage I'm wondering if you
had such array of spies in your real
life what would what would you what
would you do how would you use that
power for evil for good for good I I
despair of the world at the moment with
everything that's going on and I think
we should all be heading towards
inclusivity rather than exclusivity and
and I so I admire his his approach and I
loved that this season you got to see
him interrogate someone and it probably
wasn't what people expected but that's
just the way he works so I I like him
and most of the bad things are said
about him by people who don't like him
which is a great example of the way the
world works but I think he's so far I
mean it could turn its head I have no
idea he could have been working for
someone else the whole time but it
doesn't feel that way certainly and so I
guess I'd use it for good it seems like
you're having a ton of fun and you're
you're you're coming at it so many of
the scenes when we cut to you they play
comedic Lee in fact when you watch the
show which I find really interesting
I've been to a few of the premieres
people laugh
throughout the show and it doesn't
necessarily happen as often when you're
when you're sitting at home but there's
something about when you get together
with the community and watch it and I
think a part of that obviously with
Peter and with you it's I don't think
you're don't know I'm wondering if
you're doing that on purpose to bring a
comedic bent to it to bring a little bit
of levity or is it on the page or is it
something that it's all along the page
and some of David and Dunn's the
descriptions are hilarious
like what [ __ ] or something like that
you know but know that it's all it's
just an exquisite script and you don't
it's never it's perfect when you get it
you just go with it and we're very
grateful for that
so are we a.m. um Sophie you've had a
big year I've had a lot big year Oh big
brutal brutal year I should say Sansa
has um first question that I think a lot
of people would like to know I certainly
am one of them
why did not why didn't Sansa tell John
about the Knights of Vale that seems
like important info yeah yeah yeah
that's what I was one why do you say um
Sansa didn't tell John because she
wanted all the credit and it was a more
dramatic moment when she showed up and
it makes for really good television now
here's the question that I'm wanting
tonight why It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia didn't get an Emmy
nomination yeah I don't know you guys
have won what are you doing wrong we
haven't done enough seasons I think
we're only on season 26 it guessing 27
you guys seem to know a lot of people at
the Emmys because you've all been there
but I have never been your dates well
you deserve to be there yeah here here
we're not here for me hmm um well do you
do you believe that Sansa believes that
jon is the best fit for the Iron Throne
or do you think she may be evil
that she is someone else I don't know
about the Iron Throne
I think Sansa I think she believed it
was probably more of a joint effort for
in terms of the Battle of the bastard
she believes that they should both be
king and queen of the north for sure I
don't know about the Iron Throne I'm not
sure she's so keen on that anymore but
um I'm not sure she believes that John
is capable of running Winterfell and the
north I think she thinks he doesn't have
the intellect the knowledge the
experience that she has and I concur but
I you know she knows that he has
wonderful morals and that that kind of
those stark morals that you know
inevitably he'll make the right
decisions but all the good decision but
whether it's going to benefit anyone is
another story whatever John oftentimes
when you see an actor try to play a
badass on screen and they're not quite
pulling it off it just sort of takes you
out of it you sort of never believe that
this dainty little actor is as tough as
he or she actually looks in real life
that however is not the case with Faye
marsay pretty much channeled the
Terminator
that Evan Arnold Schwarzenegger did
stole that one yep um yeah I was like
doing a scene and I was running and then
I'm sort of mid scene and I realized
that my arms were doing this and I
thought yeah I'll keep that and did and
it went down pretty well oh yeah well so
are you it was unbelievably authentic
and so do you have any background in
martial arts or just like a badass in
real life er no I'm quite unquiet a
scaredy cat in real life I'm quite
nervous and shy actually so um spending
a month with Mayor Williams training
like gets you in the mood you know she's
really good so you want to be like as
good as her she used to hit me all the
time
and make me keep going come on Marcy
come on so we have a lot to thank me a
z4 so yeah in real life I mean I quite
like football soccer or Berea but that's
about it yeah there's a lot of
speculation that re on the way for in
fact the same person yeah which would
explain quite a bit no one else seems to
see her when she's beating up a blind
girl in the middle of braavos nobody
seems to actually notice what do you
think um I think the theory was a cool
one it would have been really cool but I
think I think Mays I think i reaiiy
sorry Owen and that's her journey and I
think yeah the way is now it's the best
way like the theory is good and it's
creative but I think they've got it
right the writer's yeah hey writers are
people reading into it too much or yeah
that's fair so Isaac Hempstead right it
plays bran bran obviously got some
pretty big info in the season finale
probably one of the biggest secrets in
the history of the show and your
character is the only one that knows
enough there's anybody in this room who
doesn't know what I'm talking about you
do not deserve to be here and I'm just
going to tell you it would appear that
Jon Snow is not in fact Ned's son at all
he is a Targaryen and therefore is a
rightful claim to the throne so what do
you think bran is going to do with that
information well first of all I don't
think we know for sure whether it's a
Targaryen that it could well be that
there's a an incest situation going on
like with the Lannisters
and definitely Anna okay
well I think bran knows that he's been
shown this information for a reason he
might not know exactly why that is but
he knows for some reason it's imperative
that he knows this and he spreads the
word but I I presume somehow he'll he'll
tell John but I don't know how John will
tank it when
Brande turns up and says by the way I'm
a tree wizard and your dad isn't your
dad just so you pretty much grew up on
the show you started when you were 11
yeah Sophie and I both started when we
were fairly young and what's it like to
be internationally famous at that age 11
7 I kind of it's fun to be here um but
you don't really know that I think you
just kind of take it as it comes and and
enjoy what comes of it I have a question
for everybody that I'd like to have
everybody answer its two-parter one I
don't think you guys should answer but
we can start with Miguel who do you
believe will win the Iron Throne and who
would you like to see on the Iron Throne
that would be telling ya I don't know to
be honest with you I I would be very
happy if they shared it but I don't
think that's gonna happen yeah well I
was the only hint that we have of this
is mr. George or Martin said that the
ending would be bittersweet which
doesn't it doesn't give too much away
and knowingly drained minds that we're
dealing with on this show it could be
anything but listen I hope I don't get
this right I have an image of him a
white Walker sitting on the throne with
put the knight king with his leg over
the arm sucking on a Cuban cigar or
their other wino anything comes to that
what do I know
and yeah it's tricky isn't it when
people ask how do you think it's gonna
turn out because you think you know what
if I'm right yeah what do you guys do
and then in two years time it flashes
back to this John Bradley spoiled it all
happy well I'd say just a pure blind
loyalty I'd say John
yeah because typically that me that I
may be in it till the end as well and
you know the wait girl
how's it basic yeah I have a similar
motive and have to say Daenerys because
I've been a loyalty thing um cuz I think
you know she's a good girl I mean she
can be very ferocious but she's
generally you know cares about people
who wants to change things I think she's
make a good Queen but at the same time
I'm so excited about the Starks also
coming back together so he knows you
know hard good point
Hey yes I know but I can't say um I I
think I want a little finger on this
rain I just hey Shan Shan Shan Shan Hey
I just think if you wanna be quirky
logistic we like that kind of thing
come on we will watch Game of Thrones
all right you got me
yeah I think they should melt the thing
down I have a democracy
I mean follow and probably Aria is photo
series you should probably beat me with
a stick I think we should have a
four-pronged
stark printing have drawn on John on the
throne sense advising are you being
people up and brandy sitting in the
corner I think I think I'm the Thrones
probably not really important by the end
of the show I think this really a he are
all between the night world of the night
king and Daenerys and I think sir she's
probably get slums and between somewhere
but on the throne I think Westeros for
once deserves someone to have with honor
and integrity and I think Brienne
Oh
you